[Music]
as republicans in dozens of states
seek new limits on how people vote 72
black current and former business
executives are taking a stand
against a sweeping new law in georgia
they put their names on look at this a
full page ad running in the new york
times today
page a7 which says quote corporate
america should publicly oppose any
discriminatory legislation
and all measures designed to limit
americans ability to vote but
they do not call for an outright boycott
of the state
two of those executives join us now to
discuss ursa brown
ursula burns rather sorry he's a former
ceo of xerox
and ken chanault is a former ceo and
chairman of american express
good morning to you both listen there
are a lot of heavy hitters on this list
including the two of you including the
two of you i know
nobody will not take the calls from
either of you so i want to know ken if
you could start us off
how did this come about did you all meet
to discuss what was it
exactly that upset you and what exactly
do you want corporate america to do but
first how's this come about
so the way it came about gail it
actually came about
sunday afternoon
for the past 10 days there has been
very heavy email traffic and text
traffic
on what was happening in georgia and in
fact
what was being proposed in close to 43
states
and what we decided was that
we needed to do something that had never
been done before
which is african-american executives
in corporate america standing up
collectively for a social issue there is
nothing more
fundamental than voting rights yeah and
the reality is what we're doing is we're
calling on companies
not to make just general statements
about the importance of voting
and voter suppression we're saying take
a stand
publicly oppose any legislation
that denies the opportunity to vote
ursula burns there was no call for a
boycott even though other people are
calling for boycotts why was the
decision not to go
that far i think that the collective
voices
of the signatories on this
letter and the reactions and voices
from early adopters will be we're hoping
will be enough
to actually see motion against
this pretty blatant and i i would say
ignorant act
so we're hoping that this step is the
step that needs to be taken
i would say not agreed broadly that if
this continues if we do not see progress
we'll have to convene again and think
about the next steps
can you know this summer when there were
protests after the death of george floyd
so many companies came out of the
woodwork making statements to now
denouncing injustice pulling out ads
commercials in your view is this your
way of urging these companies to not
just talk the talk but also walk the
walk
absolutely at the end of the day
voting rights is fundamental and here's
my point
if corporations had taken a stand
after brown v board of education
that would have made an incredible
difference
and for americans
voting is a lifeblood of democracy
and so what we're saying to companies
is all of the words are nice
but we need you to take action an action
is
to publicly oppose discriminatory
legislation in
any measures designed
is that enough just to release a
statement to make this
proclamation how will that actually
bring about change in your view how are
you hoping it does
here's what's important corporations
have
influence yes if corporations came out
and said
relative to the proposed legislation in
florida
we oppose it and in fact
work with legislators and emphasize
the importance of this i think we would
see some change
and the reality is corporations
have been silent on this issue and that
is why
we've said action has to be taken
have you had any conversation with white
corporate leaders about this
ursuline are you concerned about
backlash
i'm not concerned at all about backlash
and yes i've had a couple of
conversations with white
business leaders i think we've seen one
at least come out publicly
last night j.p morgan came out last
night in support
of our statement
on voting rights and voter suppression
and i also want to back up on ken's
point it's really important to
understand that this is not
complicated it's not scientific we're
not looking into anything about when
life begins nothing this is a right that
every american has plain and simple it's
pretty simple to implement
and what we're seeing is states starting
with georgia but other as well
others as well pushing back in a in a
kind of blatant way it's it's surprising
just how obvious this
is and we think now that in corporate
america black americans
for sure but anyone who has values in
their corporation
that talk about diversity equity and
inclusion any company
that has a value statement about valuing
their employees
has to stand with our statement because
their employees black white hispanic
women literally are going to be affected
by this type of suppression well they've
certainly been put on notice we thank
you both it's a very powerful statement